everyone has an opinion on ABC's
cancelation of Roseanne Barr show which
he plays a dogged trump supporter and
today the President himself joined the
fray rather than assess bars racist
tweet like an informer Obama a Valerie
Jarrett to an ape the president's
tweeted that Disney CEO Bob Iger called
Valerie Jarrett to let her know that ABC
does not tolerate comments like those
made by Roseanne Barr gee he never
called President Donald J Trump to
apologize for the horrible statements
made and said about me on ABC maybe I
just didn't get the call this followed a
bizarre tweet storm overnight in which
bar ripped her critics apologized and
blamed a sleep medication guys I did
something unforgivable so do not defend
me it was 2:00 in the morning and I was
ambien tweeting it was egregious
indefensible that prompted the drugs
manufacturer to declare that racism is
not a known side effect of any Santa Fe
medication now some Roseanne fans say
HBO should boot Bill Maher for once
jokingly comparing Trump's hair to an
orangutan Twitter can be a treacherous
tool for anyone in public life CNN fired
post Raisa aslan for tweeting the Trump
was a piece of s and an embarrassment to
humankind CNN also fired pro Trump
contributor Jeffrey Lord for tweeting
the Nazi salute Sieg Heil
but ESPN took no action against former
SportsCenter co-host Jamel Hill for
tweeting that Trump is a white
supremacist she was later suspended for
suggesting the Dallas Cowboys be
boycotted over player protests MSNBC did
not discipline host joy Reid for decade
old homophobic tweets she admitted were
dumb and hateful Trump's tweeting has
also drawn flak from mocking MSNBC's
Mika Brzezinski for a supposed facelift
to yesterday's unproven charge that
Robert Muller is meddling with the
midterms but he also punches back
against vicious criticism Twitter erupts
in anger so quickly that offenders can
lose their jobs and their reputations
within hours as Roseanne Barr just
learned even having TVs most popular
show doesn't protect you